and you can see that the phosphorus is
oxidized in the air and it's taken some
of the paper with it to generate a nice
P for phosphorus so this is a sample of
my favorite element this is phosphorus
phosphorus is a very very reactive
element especially this type of
phosphorus which is white phosphorus
phosphorus itself elemental phosphorus
exists is a number of different
allotropes so a bit like carbon with
diamond and graphite and here we have
one of those allotropes it's white
phosphorus it exists as discrete
molecules of four phosphorus atoms
connected like a pyramid and those four
phosphorus atoms are really strained and
really reactive and they want to really
react with oxygen as quick as they can
this is the salt that is used in
phosphorus bombs it burns very easily
and gives a very intense way and white
light out of it so instantaneously you
can see that fantastic oxidation
reaction is the phosphorus react with
the molecular oxygen in the vapor in the
gas inside the flat there you can put it
out quite easily by putting water on it
provided that it hasn't got too hot sand
the water will just evaporate very
reactive form the other allotropes black
and red phosphorus and not as as an as
reactive and a much much easier for us
to handle
then there's red phosphorus which is
very much less reactive which is what is
used in matches it's used to make the
heads of so called non-safety matches
which the ones that you can strike on
any sort of material on bricks and so on
and they tend to be this rather red
color here so the phosphorus it's you'll
notice that it's stored under water and
it's stored under water to keep the
oxygen and the atmosphere away because
it reacts very vigorously and can burn
hence the signs it's very very flammable
it's so flammable in fact that it burns
just with the heat of the skin so you
can see a number of scars across my
hands these are all from playing with
phosphorus and doing reactions and
experiments with phosphorus phosphorus
is very important point inside your body
some of you may have read all this heads
Lee's book called brave
new world which when people died they
were sent to the phosphorus reclamation
plant and each average-sized person
contains somewhat over a pound of
phosphorus inside their bodies and
nowadays people can use magnetic
resonance imaging to look and see how
the phosphorus is used inside the body
so I've taken a small sample of my white
phosphorus and I've dissolved it in an
organic solvent which is carbon
disulfide because the p4 is molecular
and it dissolves really quite nicely
this molecular solvent so now what we're
going to do is we're going to go outside
and we're going to put this on a piece
of filter paper and then let the carbon
disulphide evaporate so we can see the
reaction of the phosphorus with the
oxygen and the paper and the average
person produces inside their body about
70 kilos a day of a molecule called ATP
adenosine triphosphate which is the
energy producing molecule inside the
body
now you don't keep 70 kilos inside you
or you would explode but you're using it
up all the time but in the course of the
day you synthesize nearly 70 kilos of
this molecule so as the the carbon
disulphide evaporates from the paper
well there's a couple of drips and you
can see that the phosphorus is oxidized
in the air and it's taken some of the
paper with it to generate a nice P for
phosphorus